لذلك على الرغم من انسحاب القوات الأمريكية
من المنطقة الحدودية حيث
تشن تركيا هذه العملية العسكرية ، لا
يزال هناك أفراد عسكريون أمريكيون منتشرون
عبر أجزاء من شمال سوريا ، نحن
هنا في الولايات المتحدة.  يمكنك أن ترى في
المسافة هناك العلم الأمريكي
يتصاعد ونريد أن نحاول
فهم الأمريكيين
المتمركزين هنا كيف يشعرون تجاه
قرار USS بالسماح أساسًا
لرئيس تركيا أردوغان بالمضي قدمًا
وإطلاق هذه العملية العسكرية
ضد الأكراد ، كان الأكراد
بالطبع الحليف الرئيسي للولايات المتحدة على
الأرض في المعركة ضد داعش ،
والمثير للاهتمام أن نراه هو أنه على الرغم من أن
هذه قاعدة أمريكية إلا أنها في الواقع تحت حراستها
وتحميها القوات الكردية ، يمكنك أن
تتخيل أن الأمور يجب أن تكون  متوترين بعض الشيء
بينهما الآن ، لذلك
ليس من المستغرب أن الأمريكيين لا يريدون
التحدث إلينا في الوقت الحالي ، لقد خرج شخص ما
ليحيينا على الأقل أنهم كانوا
مهذبين للغاية لكنهم قالوا بسبب
الطبيعة الحساسة لعملهم هنا
لا يمكنهم  قل شيئًا خارج القاعدة ،
يمكنك رؤية ملصق لإحياء ذكرى جميع
المقاتلين الأكراد الذين لقوا حتفهم
في المعركة ضد مقاتلي داعش
الأكراد الذين أخبرونا عن الأمريكيين
أنهم يشعرون أنهم قد تم
بيعهم وأن الولايات المتحدة  لن تفعل
أي شيء لمساعدتهم في هذه المعركة
ضد تركيا كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن
شمال سوريا